В ефірі  новини «heute» з Мітрі Зіріним.
Вітаємо вас на недільному випуску,
про новини спорту сьогодні розповість Крістін Отто.
Так, каное і футбол, добрий вечір.
Отже, сьогодні у випуску.
Під бомбардуванням:
зіткнення між Ізраїлем та «Ісламським джихадом».
Припинення вогню має вгамувати конфлікт.
Яка позиція у партії AfD?
Лідерка Вайдель у літньому інтерв'ю для ZDF
засуджує загарбницьку війну Росії проти України.
Також дивіться про несподівані зміни в Бундеслізі:
Ентоні Модесте переходить в «Боруссію Дортмунд»,
а Тімо Вернер, ймовірно, повернеться у «РБ Лейпциг».
У ці хвилини має розпочатися перемир'я
у конфлікті на Близькому Сході,
який нещодавно спалахнув повторно.
Чи буде вогонь припинено насправді, поки невідомо.
За даними ізраїльської армії, був знешкоджений
ще один ватажок «Ісламського джихаду».
Войовничо налаштовані  палестинці відповідали
ракетними обстрілами з сектора Гази,
Єрусалим натомість здійснив авіаналіт.
Побоювання щодо початку війни дедалі зростає.
Репортаж Андреаса Кюнаста.
Сьогодні ввечері більше надії, аніж зранку,
але й більше смертей та руйнувань.
На Півдні сектора Гази військові Ізраїлю
застосували засоби ураження.
Вони були спрямовані
проти представника «Ісламського джихаду» -
командира Халеда Мансура.
Під час атаки міста Рафах
постраждали цивільні жителі,
зокрема, повідомляють про прибуття
численних карет швидкої допомоги.
Наразі відомо про п'ятьох загиблих, серед них дитина.
Вони атакували цей район без будь-яких попереджень.
Поряд стоїть лікарня.
Це дуже густонаселена місцевість.
Тут живуть діти, жінки і люди похилого віку.
Розпач та гнів сягнули й Півночі сектора Гази, Джебалії,
де загинуло п'ятеро дітей і один дорослий.
Ізраїль заявив, що причиною стала несправна ракета,
яку випустили бойовики «Ісламського джихаду».
В цей час Ізраїль не проводив
жодних дій в цьому районі.
«Ісламський джихад» вбиває дітей у Газі.
Як доказ Ізраїль публікує це відео,
на якому видно палестинську ракету,
яка рухається неправильною траєкторією.
Зображення - зброя для обох сторін,
адже все видно на камери.
Єгипет має стати посередником між сторонами,
а о 19:00 за німецьким часом почнеться
режим припинення вогню.
Ізраїль досягнув своїх військових цілей
і погодився на таку угоду.
Відповідь «Ісламського джихаду»
буде зрозуміла за кілька годин.
З Гази за останні три дні
випустили понад 500 ракет.
Ізраїлю вдалося перехопити більшість з них.
Збільшується експорт зерна з України:
ще чотири кораблі вранці покинули українські порти.
Завантажено близько 170 тис. т
зернових культур і соняшникової олії.
У цю мить судна прямують до Китаю,
Туреччини та Італії.
Через російські атаки останні кілька місяців
весь експорт зернових з чорноморських портів України
був заблокований.
Президент Відомства з охорони конституції,
Гальденванг вважає, що позиції екстремістів з партії AfD
посилились після останнього з'їзду партії.
Про це він розповів в ефірі ZDF.
Лідерка партії Аліс Вайдель заперечує це
в літньому інтерв'ю для ZDF.
Політикиня ставить під сумнів незалежність
Відомства з охорони конституції.
Ішлося також про війну в Україні,
засудження російського вторгнення
як загарбницької війни,
що суперечить міжнародному праву,
а також про помилки Заходу.
Детальніше розповість Давід Гебхард.
Аліс Вайдель вже кілька тижнів очолює партію AfD.
Партію, яка неодноразово
висловлювала розуміння нападу
Росії на Україну.
Вайдель засуджує цей акт агресії,
втім, бачить в ньому спільну відповідальність Заходу.
Росіяни завжди чітко пояснювали,
що вони не сприймуть жодної протидії
поблизу власних територій.
І той факт, що Україна
не набула нейтрального статусу, -
це помилка, за яку відповідає Захід.
З березня цього року Відомство з охорони Конституції
виказало AfD численні підозри
у правоекстремістських діях.
Також суд визнав достатніми фактичні докази
антиконституційних прагнень партії.
В червні відбулися вибори нової верхівки AfD.
Вперше після реорганізації партії
голова Відомства з охорони Конституції
висловив свою думку в ефірі ZDF:
Томас Гальденванг
Після федеральної партійної конференції AfD у Різі
ми бачимо посилення екстремістських течій у партії.
У новому федеральному виконавчому комітеті
більше немає критиків рішення
розпустити правоекстремістський «Flügel».
Вайдель не погоджується, натомість атакує владу.
Такої внутрішньої спецслужби більше ніде немає.
Захист конституції зараз політично інструменталізується,
мою опозиційну партію вкотре звинувачують.
Це робить незалежний суд, Ви маєте це вказати.
Вже встановлено, що відповідне відомство
має достатньо фактичних доказів.
AfD - нова очільниця і старі проблеми.
Відносини з Росією
і питання, як бути з крайніми правими.
Плвне інтерв'ю з Аліс Вайдель переглядайте
одразу після випуску
або у нашому застосунку.
Брак коштів для фінансування
проїзних за дев'ять євро.
Про це заявив міністр фінансів Крістіан Лінднер
в Аугсбурзі і знову чітко зазначив:
«Жага до безплатності на кшталт
безумовного базового доходу»
у галузі громадського транспорту не переконала його.
Такі квитки несправедливі,
оскільки тоді користувачі автомобілів
субсидуватимуть дешевий місцевий транспорт.
А тепер - до новин про берлінський ліс Ґруневальд.
Наразі там триває робота екстрених служб,
ситуація вкрай складна та небезпечна.
Пожежні команди повідомляють
про ще кілька осередків пожежі.
Вони намагаються звузити зону ризику
та просунутися вглиб епіцентру пожежі.
Репортаж Крістофа Дестереля.
Понад 100 тис. євро.
Такий вогнегасний робот - на вагу золота.
Він стає в пригоді, якщо треба наблизитися
на радіус 500 м до небезпечної
ділянки для проведення вибухів.
Йдеться про знешкодження
старих гранат, бомб та боєприпасів,
які все ще несуть загрозу життю.
Хоча більшість осередків пожежі з четверга згасли,
ґрунт досі занадто гарячий.
Два роботи охолоджують його водою.
Позаду них повільно просуваються пожежники.
Зокрема, завдяки допомозі інших служб.
До нас прибуває вибухотехнік,
який постійно оцінює ситуацію на місці,
коли працівники нашої служби знаходять
в лісі підозрілий предмет,
який вони не можуть класифікувати.
Незалежно від того, становить він загрозу чи ні.
Поточна оцінка ситуації:
на Авусі, шосе поблизу місця вибухів, і досі небезпечно.
Принаймні до завтрашнього ранку
транспортне сполучення на ньому буде припинене,
однак колії поблизу вже знову введені в роботу,
маршрут «Берлін - Потсдам» знову доступний.
Але чому спалахнув вогонь і сталися вибухи?
Важко сказати, оскільки слідчі досі
не зуміли перетнути межу забороненої зони.
Потрапити до неї наразі неможливо.
Отара овець пасеться майже
безпосередньо на місці вибухів,
там вони зазвичай харчуються травою.
Тварини отримують воду з поїлок.
Ми маємо переконатися, що там є вода.
Ситуація ще не критична,
тому пастуху не дозволяється пройти в заборонену зону.
Тут може знадобитися водомет,
він заповнить поїлки для овець з безпечної відстані.
Після повеней в Каліфорнійському національному парку
«Долині Смерті» працюють рятувальники.
Сотні людей евакуйовано в безпечне місце.
В п'ятницю раптово почалася сильна повінь.
За даними управління парку,
перекрито всі під'їзні дороги,
а десятки автомобілів загрузли у багнюці.
Долина Смерті має славу
одного з найсухіших і найспекотніших місць в США.
А тепер - до теми спорту і
золотих призерів Чемпіонату світу, Крістін.
Отож, почнімо.
Після п'яти вчорашніх медалей, серед яких
жодної золотої, сьогодні видався плідніший день:
Чемпіонат світу з веслування
на каное в канадському Галіфаксі приніс
одну бронзову та дві срібні медалі,
а також два чемпіонських титули
для німецьких спортсменів.
У веслуванні на каное-двійці на дистанції 1000 м
глядачі спостерігали
чудовий фінальний спринт
Себастьяна Бренделя і Тіма Гекера.
Вони випередили команди з Китаю та Канади.
Після вчорашнього четвертого
місця на дистанції 500 м -
це приємне завершення Чемпіонату світу.
Для Себастьяна Бренделя це вже
одинадцяте «золото» на ЧС.
Несподіваним, але приємним став тріумф
Мартіна Гіллера і Тамаса Гроссмана
у веслуванні на байдарках-двійках на дистанції 1000 м.
Вони значно випередили команди Італії та Угорщини.
Про футбол: у першій недільній грі на відкритті Бундесліги
в поєдинку зійшлися Лейпциг проти Штутгарта
з результатом 1:1.
Різні ЗМІ повідомляють, що повернення нападника
Тімо Вернера з ФК «Челсі» в «РБ Лейпциг»,
імовірно, таки відбудеться.
А дортмундська «Боруссія» досягла попередньої
домовленості з ФК «Кельн»
щодо трансферу Ентоні Модесте.
Кельн втрачає улюбленця вболівальників
та найкращого нападника.
Вдень новину підтвердив директор ФК
Крістіан Келлер.
На прохання Ентоні Модесте
сьогодні вдень ми досягли
домовленості з «Боруссія Дортмунд»
щодо переходу гравця.
Спортивний директор «Боруссії» Себастьян Кель
зробив схожу заяву.
Четвертий найкращий бомбардир минулого сезону
Бундесліги з 20 голами на рахунку
має компенсувати відсутність
Себастьєна Алле в «Боруссії».
ЗМІ також повідомляють
про можливе повернення Тімо Вернера
з «Челсі» до «РБ Лейпциг».
Це досить несподівано,
оскільки лейпцизький тренер Доменіко Тедеско
нещодавно заявляв,
що він повністю задоволений нинішнім складом команди.
Цікава подія в рік Чемпіонату світу.
Саме так.
Фінал очікуємо у переддень Різдва.
Дякую Крістін.
Погода по-літньому спекотна,
а деревам потрібна волога.
Подивімося, що ж чекає на нас.
Завтра на півночі час від часу
буде хмарно, загалом приємна погода.
І далі стоятимуть сухі днини з високим ризиком
виникнення лісових пожеж.
Температури коливатимуться від 21 до 32°C.
О 21:45 рекомендуємо переглянути
«heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Дякуємо за перегляд та бажаємо гарного вечора.